the boss keep forgetting this show I
started to watch I watched the first
three episodes and I absolutely [ __ ]
loved it and I tweeted about it it was a
cartoon from Japan I guess they're
called anime which I didn't know that
but I didn't realize it was such a
divisive thing to say that you like the
show that was anime it's anime like the
emo of [ __ ] cartoons like I tweeted
that I like this show called one punch
man
[Music]
all right
and the [ __ ] responses that I got I
got dude you [ __ ] drunk oh my god
you're into anime and then other people
just like this is like the greatest day
ever
I just like to show I've watched enough
for the same type of [ __ ] and I was
scrolling through and I was like what
the [ __ ] is this show and I looked and
it had five stars four and a half five
stars which is why I really hope the
Netflix doesn't go to thumbs up thumbs
down like I said because it's so [ __ ]
you know stubbing your toe thumbs down
Adolf Hitler thumbs down I mean the
thumbs down is Justin there's a big gap
between Hitler and you know stopping
your [ __ ] toe
anyway so I put this thing on and what I
loved about the show aside from the fact
I really thought it was funny you
actually kind of got like a sense of
what young people feel like in Japan as
far as their view of going into the
corporate world was very similar to the
empty feeling unless you're a [ __ ]
sociopath over here I find like a very
like common thread to that and basically
give you the overall thing the superhero
in it he's not a super he doesn't want
to be a superhero when I'm out fighting
monsters
I never feel as if my heart's really in
it anymore
I mean I just did the hero thing as a
hobby all right and he [ __ ] trained
really hard because you want to be the
strongest guy in the world and in his
training he lost all his hair which is
hilarious and he's really self-conscious
about it but he ended up developing like
this punch and no matter what monster he
runs into he doesn't give a [ __ ] whether
they kill him he's just completely
devoid of any like passion or emotion
like what happens to you when you get
shoved into a [ __ ] cubicle
[Music]
and and he's got this one punch and he
just [ __ ] can punch so hard that no
matter how [ __ ] bad-ass the monster
is he gives him one some he said they
should have called the shoulder right
there friend he gives him the [ __ ]
BAM in the [ __ ] and in the face is
Eddie Murphy says it's a fake and their
[ __ ] head explodes and the monsters
that he fights you also get more of an
insight into where people's heads are at
in Japan and it was like you know one of
the months cause he fought with some
giant virus sent here by the earth to
get rid of the all the humans because of
what we've done to the planet so those
environmental thing then my favorite one
was this guy who was crab man he was
half like up top and he was all a crab
and then the bottom he was he was half a
guy and he was in the bottom half he's
in his bare feet and tighty whiteys said
you're a new businessman already hating
the daily grind I ate too much crab and
turned into this crab one day you should
be crapping in your pants right now why
aren't you running he and the guys like
oh I ate so much crab meat that I became
a [ __ ] crab and to me he represented
the upper 1% corporate guys you know on
some Power Lunch just eating all the
[ __ ] sushi and just take take take
take take nothing spiritual about him
so he gave him the old right there Fred
[Applause]
and then he fought this [ __ ] leg and
she had command of all the mosquitos and
she picked the mosquitos on everybody
suck all the blood out of you and all
your [ __ ] energy and then it would
make her stronger and to me it's like oh
this is a gold-digging blood sucking
[ __ ] right uh-huh come on that wasn't
nearly enough blood to satisfy my name
now go get some more for me and then
once you got it to do it to all the
animals and everybody there she didn't
need the mosquitos anymore she told all
the mosquitos to go [ __ ] themselves and
I'm like slash this is also somebody who
becomes successful and forgets where
they come from and they look at
everybody where they used to be like a
bunch of [ __ ] peons a bunch of little
insignificant little mosquitos I no
longer need my tiny little helpers I
mean
[Music]
look at how strong guys become right
it's a lot of levels - or you can just
get [ __ ] high and watch this
bald-headed dude [ __ ] punch half a
crab in the head who want you to explode
I enjoyed it
oh hey Bellamy CBS oh hi Bonnie comes in
the parade comes now going down Broadway
it's a one-way street whichever way I go